I love Jay Z.
We'll get so specific that you think he's actually stopped recording and like
some real is going on. Thanksgiving tend to get out dishes. Oh wait. Oh. Stop.
Oh, wait. No, you're wrapping. Okay, cool. Oh yeah.
I can't say the N word, so, Oh yeah.
These bleep is coming. Get out.
You could dishes or something like is Thanksgiving, first of all. No, for sure.
Get out your good dishes or something so secure.
I mean then the next night is, and none other than that are,
and without further ado, I like like Freddy, get ready.
It's I mean just and okay. Whatever, but you know,
don't need to go all into that really, but, so
he's. He's making to attacking document parking lot
here. JZ send security. Laughs.
Got to duck into the parking lot. Hove,
I guess hope, I guess. Did you see the video of Beyonce?
just straight up molding that girl who was trying to talk to
her, Jay Z and lean over Beyonce.
And the girl was like at the basketball game and she was one of the Clippers
owners or Lakers owners or whatever the who cares.
One of the golden state warriors owners.
And she leaned over and she was like talking to Jay Z and she leaned
over, um, Jay Z or uh,
Beyonce and Beyonce kind of like shifted. So she wouldn't do it.
And now here's what the annoying people are saying. Oh yeah.
Beyonce. Didn't like how she was talking to her man. No,
it's not that the lady was,
it's just leaning over too much and that's annoying a little bit.
Sometimes also there's probably that whole thing where even though
she was like, uh, one of the, um, golden state warriors owners' wives, it was,
it still was like, you know,
still like where it was like a don't act like,
you know us dude, you're not with us. You know?
So JZ was talking back all cool and, and be outside,
just kind of gave a little bit of a look that was nothing.
But then the beehive, as they say,
we're giving her death threats. Hey chill, Hey Beyonce,
fans chill. Hey,
also you call yourself the beehive, you know, in
non-ironic terms, look at her, just,
she obviously just kind of is like,
what's up with this lady and then just kind of shucks are a little bit it's
kinda cool, dude. Cause the lady was just like leaning away too far over,
but who cares? See that's the thing. Hey, what are you doing?
That's what you gotta do. Don't shuck. She's Beyonce. She can't get,
get crazy with it. I was thinking about this. Like I was thinking about this.
Um, I don't remember what the example was, but
man, imagine being so famous because you could only be so famous if you're like,
if you don't say crazy, up.
And then if you do,
it's because you're famous because of that, there's,
there's different levels of it, but it's like, um,
you can get as famous as like Dennis Rodman was a lot of young
people probably don't know who they, who they, who he is,
but he was a basketball player that was like fake, crazy,
famous for being crazy. You can get that famous, but
uh, you can,
then you can only if you're already really famous, he turned us off.
There's if you're already really famous, you can't get,
and then you start doing crazy. Like, um, like Charlie sheen,
you can't sustain that bother me.
You can't sustain that for a long, too long.
Like when Charlie sheen was like tiger blood and winning,
like that only lasts as long as it can.
And then it blows over because he wasn't famous for being crazy.
He was famous for being a famous actor war.
You can be the most like crazy famous,
but then you can't say anything like counter Reeves or Tom cruise
or Harrison Ford.
Like if all of a sudden Harrison Ford put out a video that was like,
you know, if Harrison Ford, all of a sudden put out a video,
like how my video was making fun of Armenians last week have Harrison
Ford was like, how come Armenia is like, love to say like,
Hey, don't disrespect me. People will be like, Oh,
Harrison Ford is what the is.
People be like Harrison Ford for saying the. So like,
that would be my nightmare to be maybe Harrison. Ford's not the best example.
But to be like that famous to where you can't say the like,
like Jennifer Garner, like if she just said that people would be like, Oh,
she lost her mind, dude.
I that's to not be like that.
Not be able to say what you want to me.
That's crazy. That's so insane that that would be the worst for me.
And I realize I'll never, you know, be that,
the only way I could get there to get as famous that famous is to be because of
I'm an insane person, you know, like it to be a literal.
Like if I did, if I had like a, it was a serial killer,
then that would only add to it and you'd be like, wow,
this crazy comedian who had a podcast.
And just talking about how he made a cult, literally started killing people,
literally started killing businessmen and killed 12
businessmen. If I was going to kill people though,
it will be businessmen in suits, straight up, not if they,
if they got out of their suit and I had the knife ready and they were like,
Oh the guy other. I'm not doing it. We'll be like live tonight at 11,
talking about comedian crystal
live at 11. We have to be talking about Chris meat. They wouldn't even,
they would disrespect me by having new new news at 3:00 AM that nobody listened
to. We live it's 3:00 AM.
We're talking about the comedian turned serial killer.
Chris D'Elia once had a spat with Albuquerque and now has killed
at least 13 businessmen with suits on,
uh, I would give all the interviews too. I did too, dude.
I keep my phone up my butt, go to jail and do live videos after that.
And you'd see all over the lens. It's gross at gross,
but that's why you're hearing my babies.